all right Ashley Yeah Ashley where'd you
grow up where are you from I'm
originally from California
um I lived in Sacramento Carmichael
um
until about uh nine years old or so
what was your childhood like
um uh it was uh was my first adopted
mother she kind of went out of her way
to make sure that she wasn't there being
good didn't get me anywhere so I started
being bad and that's when I got all the
attention was being bad and
um I would say that she was she pretty
much just uh when she didn't want me
anymore she left me was across state
from California to Washington State
Addie with some Amish people
so um I would say that that part of my
life is more
abandonment issues so this was your
adopted my first one what was your
biological mom's story I never knew my
birth parents
um the only thing that I know about her
is she was a prostitute I'm a product of
a prostitute I was told that the dad
supposedly may be Puerto Rican I don't
know
I never knew I've been searching my
whole life unfortunately for me my file
is sealed I would have to petition the
court for those kind of information I
don't have so your first adopted mom
abandoned you at what age nine yeah I
was nine with an Amish family yeah it
was Amish and I was there for like three
months before the pastor kind of was
like yeah she's not out here anymore I
was already set my ways like there's a
certain way to be when you're Amish and
I love the fact that they're hard
workers but it's not my religion
um this was in Washington state yeah
Addie Addie Washington it's a really
small small community
um I was only there for three months but
to have your life altered from the one
thing to Bonnet long sleeve dresses and
like at that age maybe dress was cool
every once in a while but not always
you know what I mean and it was a very
strict
um family I mean they were
um kind of weird themselves but I would
say that I learned how to sew really
well
um after that I went to some Mormon
family and they were the my second
adoption I went from Ashley Myers to
Ashley Johnson
and
um you know that it does put a damper in
things nowadays because with ID and
stuff you have no idea how hard it is to
get my ID at my age with different last
names yeah no I don't um uh thankfully
for me I I'm still in the system so I'm
I'm good there
how was that family
um they were really abusive from the
time that I said yes to the judge and
they took me home they took a shaver to
my head and made me bald
and I was to go work for them I would
say that I was more than whitewashed to
I don't know why they did that to me but
I'm at a culture shock room when you
live in 100 people population you're not
gonna understand this and for me it's
it's
um it could be an unhealthy thing but I
kind of like the way I turned out
because it's different it's not like
what everybody would think you know how
long how long were you with the Amish
family or the Mormon family
um from nine to twelve but uh CPS
finally took me away I by then I weighed
35 pounds and I had softball Mark like
bruises and welts and on me all over
from from being abused they take two by
fours to me they
um they were just really bad I mean they
I was their slave that's what they told
me I was I'm cursed with the black skin
they like certain Mormons believe that
if you're a certain color you were
cursed and I guess it had something to
do with Abel killing Kane and
that was the curse and so I was led to
believe that being my color was bad
and I was punished for it
then after that family you went where I
went uh I went into the foster care
business
I bounced around so much it would have
made your heads then I I couldn't tell
you all the families that I remember I
was very abused though most of my life
what kind of stuff you go through
in the Foster system
um
when you're not a family and you are the
one looking on on the inside you see
this family and and you want them to
love you just the same but they don't
they don't treat you like a part of the
family and and instead of loving me I
would sit there and watch them open
presents like during Christmas or
whatever and they were always telling me
Oh they weren't allowed to do that with
me they were allowed to give me presents
or whatever and so I just kind of always
felt like an outcast I was always an odd
one out of the bunch
um never I never felt loved at all in
any home that I was ever placed in
um I've always thought it was very weird
that they only stuck me in white homes
the closest dark family I ever got to
was a Filipino family I still talked to
her though her name is Teresita Alvarado
and she's a great person I love her very
much
um but I kind of I pushed that one away
based on things that have happened to me
I I run away from good things now you
know
that's hard to explain but when you're
when you're abused your whole life you
think that's gonna happen again you just
end up you know separating yourself from
anything that could could possibly
happen
how old are you now I'm 37 or 38 I just
turned 38. 38 and you've been spending
your
how many years on the streets I've been
on the street for 20 years
on and off
um
I
I had everything kind of go downhill for
me and
um
it's hard to describe what I go through
I had both of my kids die in the same
year
and I couldn't handle it
I kind of went off the deep end when
that happened
and uh
my kids would have been probably about
18 17 by now
um how'd you lose your children
um
it's hard to explain
my first uh my first son I gave up for
adoption
I was actually getting raped I have like
Burns right here on my back where my my
butt is so I would always have to
remember what happened to me I was a
virgin
and I ended up pregnant
this being said it's also like I was
never supposed to have kids so it's kind
of a miracle baby not not the way that I
wanted it to happen but um I don't
believe in abortion so I gave him up for
adoption
um
I don't know they told me that he died
from heart failure and lack of oxygen he
was four years old
um my second son
was three and the father of my child
strangled him to death
um I have to say that I've never cried
about my kids I'm more than numb from
everything that has happened I've had to
pretend like it doesn't hurt me because
of where I'm at in my life you can't be
like just crying like a baby out here
and you know people aren't gonna care
anyway
so I just hold it in
but
um but it's starting to hurt physically
emotionally and spiritually I don't I
mean like as a woman you're not supposed
to
um hide that you know like a woman is
supposed to be sensitive and so
um I've been trying to figure out a way
because it hurts holding it all in not
having anybody to talk to and
or to even understand that where I went
like I I like I went I was at like one
of these creeper Types on the street
okay I lost myself entirely
you know and I couldn't tell you what
happened within those two years all I
remember is what was told to me I came
back and like maybe not on 110 level but
to come back the way I come back is a
true blessing
I couldn't describe to you the feeling
that I had
it's really hard
to be mean when I see these kids and
not having family not having anybody to
understand
what it's like
to wonder if you're gonna be raped
are you gonna be safe you know how you
walk these streets
every day you hope that something better
happens
people don't understand that it's
different for some females I don't judge
anybody do what you do but be safe about
it you know what I mean
I told myself I would never do that to
myself but yet that did happen I was a
prostitute from 18 to 21.
and what stopped me was my friend got
into an argument with her guy and she
got into the wrong car a car she
normally wouldn't have gotten into was
stabbed 39 times her name was Jenna
she was my best friend
and the guy killed himself afterwards so
there's no justice when that happens but
before she died she made me promise to
stop doing it that I had more to offer
than that than I haven't done it since
it becomes very real when those things
happen like
when you realize Ferdinand it's just
ridiculous you know how people are
nowadays
not a drop of a dime kids are killing
kids and you're wondering what is going
on you never expected that [__] to
happen the way it's happening now
you know what I mean
um
you just keep on getting up and you just
keep going because you think that
there's going to be some like a way of
success but honestly without local
people there can I mean local people
have to help they have to start caring
because I'm I'm willing to do whatever
it takes to not have to do this anymore
you know I'm I'm so scared at night
wondering if I'm gonna be okay
then you know just the idea that I have
had those things happen more than one
time because I couldn't fight somebody
off me makes me feel some type of way
that should never happen to anybody ever
I would give up everything to not have
that happen to anybody
I'm proud of myself for the for the
morals that I have and for the for the
stuff that I'm willing to do now to to
get people to understand that like this
is not what I'm choosing right now
I am an addict I do crystal every day
and I feel like the only way I stay safe
is when I do my crystal usually at night
that way if I'm awake who can hurt me if
I'm awake I'm gonna stay around people
where there's more people and you know
things like that aren't going to happen
when there's a lot of people around you
you know what I mean
you know and so I utilize it to keep me
safe
um
I don't know I know that I would I wish
I never knew anything about it
I I don't think that I'm any different
though to be honest like as far as like
the way I think and the way I feel about
things I feel like I'm just the same
person I still care but I think I care
more now than I did before because I see
something that I didn't see before it's
like
after all those things that have
happened to me I'm still alive you know
and I can be a true like leader somehow
or let people know that just because
he's happened to me doesn't mean that I
can't be great for it
what do you worry about now which was
your biggest fear being raped again yeah
my biggest fear is being raped again I
don't I don't ever want to go through
that ever again
my biggest fear is not being like
trusting somebody too much
to that point like
or you know never finding love never
finding what it is that I need at my age
I'm supposed to want to settle but I'm
so scared that I run away from it like I
I would purposely go out of my way to
sabotage myself from having anything
good because I don't want to be hurt and
I don't know whether these people are
gonna hurt me or are they being real
money what is real anymore when you when
you look outside of the box like to me
it's like this place is this
it has definitely changed me in ways
that I never thought possible
you imagine how your life would have
been differently different if you had
been loved by
you sure that it would be a lot
different
um
I imagine what it would have been like
but for me I think that
it's not who your family is really I
have adopted so many great people out
here are my family
uh Street family means more sometimes
than blood
um what I'd like to know my birth
parents I would give up everything to
know at least my birth mom I want to
tell her that I forgive her
and that I love her still I want to give
her a hug
material I love her there's a bond there
that you can't break like no matter what
you do I don't have to know where to
love her but I just wish I had the
opportunity to decided to tell her you
know it means everything to me that she
she knows that
I'm living on the streets for females
very difficult you get depressed and
yeah scared I'm sure more than more than
I more than I used to but at my age it's
it's a really weird age that I'm going
through
um nobody told me about the woman stuff
that happens to you and so I'm having to
figure it out by myself and so it's like
you know I'm going through what you call
a early
pre-monopausaling State I haven't been
able to have kids since I was 23 I had
to get fixed I have cervical cancer so
um I don't know I haven't checked it out
lately because I decided to give it all
to God and whatever happens is going to
happen I mean death is gonna is gonna
happen to all of us eventually one day
and if I have to die from then that's
fine because I really believe that I've
I've seen some beautiful things sad
things things that have made me angry
I've gone through life and I've I've
seen myself growing ways that I never
thought possible
you know and just I mean like recently
like I want to say within the last four
years I went blind four years ago and my
right eye and
um it enlightened me because you don't
realize what like spiritually that it
could open up my a sense that I never
thought I had
um and basically it's like
um I feel like I can see things on a
different level spiritually than I did
before like even if I lost everything to
my name I still woke up somehow and
still got it again you know how many
times I've gone through like coming up
on anything like clothes or whatever and
I have to re replace it
you know and but those are the things
that I'm grateful for that I have a
talent that I I I'm good with people you
know and and I decided that I didn't
need Bad Karma so I need a good karma
and um
I I've been doing everything in my power
to show that and and I actually have
friends now I've never had friends
before this place which is really weird
but I feel like there's a few select
people
that I can really honestly say are my
friends
um
and I think that they would have my back
at least
how do you support yourself now
um well
I kind of like I wing it every day
um I I will knock on doors see if people
need house cleaning
um I'll I'll uh I don't technically
boost anymore but I used to back in
Vegas
um
I don't do that now what I do for people
is I'll watch the stuff
or I will be the diversion
and like I'll go and fall out have a
seizure while they come make the getaway
it's fun sometimes sometimes it's really
fun to you know play the part and help
your friend out I'll get a percentage of
whatever they decide to give me I'm not
a greedy person I decided that like you
know if you're going to help somebody do
it because you want to not because you
have to
if you had your life to live all over
again would you have done things
differently
exact same thing because I feel like
you can't regret anything
you know this is the I feel like I'm the
one that's gonna be on top one day and
you're gonna see a completely different
person one day and because I can rise
above all of it you know what I mean
it's just because I'm in a rut now it
doesn't mean anything to me this is
nothing
uh God made me special I feel like for a
reason you know I went through what I
needed to go through for a reason and I
don't have to understand it but I do
believe that like if I wasn't who I am
now I don't think I'd be alive
because I was making really bad
decisions I used to be on heroin and
heroin made me an evil person like I'm
so glad that I really got off of that I
didn't do methadone clinic or any of
that I just saw myself one day and it
scared me shitless and that was done it
was done
that was it never again last time I ever
dabbled and that was Vegas and then I
only took a line or like a hit here and
a hit there but not nothing like like I
had tar for veins okay back when I was
when I was doing it
I want to say it was like 95 pounds at
18 and that's not good like
you know
um
so I have to say that like I've been off
of heroin for 15 years now
and I'm proud of that
I just need to conquer this last Beast
you know the last one is my crystal
addiction and I feel like it's a need
right now and I feel like it keeps me
safe
and and even if you can't understand
that imagine you know
sleeping somewhere where you thought was
a good place to sleep
and you passed out and then Here Comes
weirdos and he couldn't have done
anything about it and how are you going
to fight off four or five guys it's not
going to happen you know
and I mean I would die trying and and
the incidents that have happened to me
were based on the fact that I said no
you know I wasn't gonna be
um prostituting or doing what they said
because they're used to hearing yes all
the time I'm just not I'm not doing it
they'll have to kill me dude like for
real
I'm not going through that ever again
that's why I'm I want people to
understand that I'm willing to work for
mine I'm willing to do whatever it takes
to you tell me what to do and I'll do it
you know but I feel like you gotta
understand that like
I feel like it's it's not fair to not
hire me based on the fact that I don't
have ID I feel like you should hire me
because I'm the one that's willing to do
whatever that it is that needs to be
done
and I'll do it for free the first day
just to prove myself like you know that
it's sad that I would you know I'm I
would beg ever but I would rather have
work than to
like the feeling when you buy something
and then when you have to steal
something is completely totally
different feelings and for me I was
proud of myself when I was working and I
was able to buy my stuff the smile that
I would get versus now I get that look
like she's gonna still you know you know
that look it's like you're across the
street and there's a guy across the
street he's still checking his pockets
and while he's looking at you like I
have some go go gadget arms you know
like come on dude like I'm across the
street I'm not gonna how am I gonna get
you from over here like people are like
that though nowadays and I get it but
don't judge a book by its cover
actually what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
and what I said don't don't judge a book
by its cover and I would say that love
is the greatest thing in the world
it can conquer anything I mean
was the morals that I have and I've had
these things happen to me with my kids
dying and I still continue to love I
feel like you gotta you have to open up
your heart you have to be willing
to try
and and see it from somebody else's
point of view put their shoes on
and walk to like you know I I would like
to dare people to try it one day go out
there without your wallet one week do
one week and see how you do
without your wallet without your ID
seeing how hard it truly is and then
tell me
that oh it's a piece of cake because
it's not
you know I I challenge somebody that has
that going on for them to see what it's
like just once because you're not gonna
know until you do it and I guarantee
it's going to be somebody homeless that
will help you more than somebody that
you know that's rich or somebody that
you know that you know high-end so I
would say that's what I've learned I
haven't learned anything
but I've learned to Love More
all right Ashley thank you so much for
sharing your story
I wish you lots of luck out there
thank you